[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIKHIL KAUL: Hello, everyone.
Thanks a lot for coming.
Today, we are here to discuss
how you can develop, deploy,
and debug applications using
Google Cloud platform's
Developer Tools.
I'm Nikhil Kaul.
I'm the product marketing
manager for Developer Tools
at Google Cloud.
And with me, I have Russell.
RUSSELL WOLF: I'm Russell Wolf,
and I'm the product manager
for Cloud Source Repositories.
NIKHIL KAUL: So
as you might have
seen in the previous
slide, the way
we structured this
presentation is essentially
into three parts.
In the first and
the foremost part,
we specifically wanted to talk
about developing applications.
In the second part,
we wanted to showcase
how you can deploy
those applications.
And in the third
part, we specifically
wanted to deep dive
into debugging an app.
In the first part, when
we talk about developing
an application, we
wanted to deep dive
into how you can store your
source code on Google Cloud
Platform, the different
integrations which
are available to make developers
productive as a part of storing
that source code, and finally,
the different features which
are available to
build security in.
In the second part,
which is essentially
targeted at deploying,
we wanted to showcase
how you could use Cloud Source
Repositories specifically
to build, test,
and deploy an app.
And finally, in the third
phase of the presentation,
we wanted to showcase how
you can use Cloud Source
Repositories along with
the different integrations
with Stack Driver for
debugging in applications.
The one thing which you
would see across these three
different phases is we are
leveraging Cloud Source
Repositories along with
the different integrations
it provides.
So just to level set and
ensure everyone in the audience
understands what Cloud
Source Repositories is,
we go to the next slide.
RUSSELL WOLF: Cloud
Source Repositories
is a generally
available service on GCP
that allows you to host
private Git repositories.
Because those repositories
are hosted on GCP,
it makes it really easy to
integrate with other GCP
services, such as
Stackdriver Debugger, Cloud
Build, and Cloud Pub/Sub.
There are three areas where
Cloud Source Repositories
really excels.
First, is with its
high scalability.
Google has invested in a highly
scalable Git infrastructure
for many years to support the
needs of two of the largest Git
projects that exist--
Chromium and Android.
Cloud Source Repositories uses
that same highly scalable Git
infrastructure,
which means that you
can host large files, large
folders, large repositories,
and do it all for many users
with a very low latency.
Next, Cloud Source Repositories
has high reliability,
because all repositories are
hosted in multiple data centers
across different regions.
In theory, even if half
of the world's network
was disconnected,
all repositories
would still be
able to be served.
We even isolate data centers
and perform periodic disaster
recovery tests, just to be
sure your source code is safe.
And finally, to help meet
your organization's compliance
needs, Cloud Source
Repositories doesn't just
integrate with identity
and access management,
meaning that you get to use
the same identity you use
for the rest of
your organization,
and use a consistent
permission model used
with the rest of
your cloud resources.
It also features audit logging,
which means that if something
were to go wrong, such
as codex filtration,
you can be sure that you
can do an investigation
and figure out what
happened, who did it,
and when it happened.
Cloud Source
Repositories also does
daily globally
redundant backups.
Which means that if some
disaster were to occur,
your source code is safe.
And finally, with
automatic encryption
in transit with per
repository encryption keys,
your IP is protected.
NIKHIL KAUL: So
remember the three
pieces of the presentation--
develop, deploy, and debug?
So let's start with the first
phase of how Cloud Source
Repositories can actually
help you develop applications.
RUSSELL WOLF: There are two
ways to connect your source
code to GCP.
First, you can do it
by mirroring your code
from an external Git provider,
such as GitHub or Bitbucket.
You only need to set
up that mirror once,
and all of your source
code is copied over.
After that, anytime you
make a new commit to GitHub
or Bitbucket, that
commit is then
copied over to Cloud Source
Repositories, as well.
Now you may be
asking the question,
what benefits do I get from
copying my source code over
to GCP?
Well first, you can take
advantage of code search.
We'll dive into
that a bit later.
But I can just tell you that
Googlers rely on it every day.
And I bet you'll
find it great too.
Second, you can take
advantage of a bunch
of other integrations that
Cloud Source Repositories
has with other GCP services.
For example, Cloud
Pub/Sub, Cloud Build,
and Stackdriver Debugger.
And we'll also demo
all of those later.
Alternatively, you can choose to
host your source code directly
on Google Cloud Platform in
Cloud Source Repositories
and have your entire development
team collaborate there.
Next.
We're also excited to announce
an upcoming integration
with GitLab, which
means that you'll
be able to host your
repositories on GitLab
and mirror all that source code
into Cloud Source Repositories
to take advantage of all
of those integrations.
This will be available
in the next month.
NIKHIL KAUL: The other
goal of us providing
Cloud Source
Repositories is making
developers more productive.
And traditionally,
what we see is
developers spend a lot
of time trying to find
answers each and every day--
answers to questions like how
a function should be called,
what does the class look
like, where does the class
get instantiated, why
is something failing,
or who changed
the code resulting
into the code base failing?
And answers to those
questions can be easily found
through code search
functionality of Cloud Source
Repositories.
Code search allows you to search
across your entire repository
with a single query.
This is especially
useful when you
don't have all of your
organization's repositories
cloned down from the server
to your local machine,
or all of your local
repos aren't up to date
with the server.
Indexing is super fast.
So even if you're in a large
organization with commits
constantly coming
in, you're always
searching against
up-to-date code.
In fact, Cloud
Source Repositories
uses the same document indexing
and retrieval mechanisms
used by Google
search, which means
that it can handle your
searches quickly and across very
large corpuses of code.
There are three areas where
code search for Cloud Source
Repositories really excels.
First, with support for
regular expression search.
That means you can craft
queries to answer even the most
complex of questions.
Second, by having a
syntax-aware index.
That means that you're not
just searching for text,
you can also search for
specific entity types,
such as a class or a function.
And finally, with results
suggestions as you type,
you can get answers
to the questions
you're looking for right
away, without having
to wade through any
search result pages.
Cloud Source
Repositories also helps
you keep your code secure.
It's generally not a good
idea to check service account
credentials or security keys
into a version control system.
However, sometimes you
may accidentally do that.
And that's where Cloud Source
Repositories is there to help.
With the Pushblock
feature enabled,
if you try to push a commit to
the server that contains a GCP
service account credential
or a security key,
that push will be blocked.
And you'll be given
information telling you
what file was in violation
and why it was blocked.
If your commit was just fine,
it makes it to the server.
Let's go ahead and take a
look at a demo for this all.
We're first going to
start by showing how you
sync a repository from GitHub.
Then we'll take a look at the
source browser in Cloud Source
Repositories and look at the
contents of that repository.
After that, we'll do
a global code search.
And finally, we'll
take a look and see
how Pushblock works in action.
This is the home page of
Cloud Source Repositories.
Here, you can see your favorites
and your recently viewed.
And these will contain
repositories, branches,
folders, and files.
It helps you quickly jump back
into the context of whatever
you were last working on.
We can go up to the top right
and select Add Repository,
to add a new repository.
And here, we can choose
between connecting
an external repository, or
creating a new repository.
We're going to choose to
connect an external repository.
We're going to add it
to this cloud project
I created specifically for Next.
And we'll choose
the GitHub provider.
I'm going to authenticate
GCP to connect to GitHub.
And I've already signed
in with my GitHub
account on this computer,
so I'm already in here.
And I'm going to choose to
connect this cloud debugger
Python repository that I
have access to on GitHub.
I just click Connect
Selected Repository.
And now, Cloud
Source Repositories
is setting up a web hook
on that GitHub repository.
That way, whenever changes
happen to that repo,
we can then mirror
the changes back over.
And it's also doing a one-time
full clone of that repository,
including all the branches,
and tags, and everything else.
It looks like that repo
has been cloned over,
so let's take a look.
Here, we can see the
layout of the repository.
In this branch
picker at the top,
we can see that it's copied
over all the branches, tags,
and commits.
We can also see the README file
for the repository rendered
here and click
into Change History
to see the history of
all of the comments
that have happened
in this repository.
As we navigate through the
source browser, navigating
through folders and
even down to files,
we can see that the Change
History updates for that scope.
Once you're looking
at a file, you
can click [? Blame ?]
to see which
user was responsible for the
changes on each line of code
and see the associated commit
and message that goes along
with it.
You can also go
to Change History
and select a [? diff ?] between
any two versions of a file.
And you can click on a commit ID
to view all of the changes that
took place in that commit.
Finally, you can
compare those commits
to other commits
in your repository
and see the difference
of all the commits
that happened in
between, as well as
all the changes to the files.
Let's go ahead and take
a look at the code search
functionality now.
I'm going to change
from searching
in this repository to
searching across everything
I have access to.
And as you can see, as I
type individual characters,
I'm getting these results
suggestions as I type.
And they're showing that it's
finding variables, functions,
[? struts, ?] and more.
I can go ahead and click on
one of these suggestions,
and I'm taken directly
to the line of code
where that function exists.
I can also go the search box
and just submit this query
and view all of the results
across all of the repositories
I have access to.
You can go in and
preview all the matches
in the file to see if it's
what you're looking for
and continue iterating through
these different previews
until you find the exact match
that you were trying to get to.
This really helps
your developers
be productive and solve
those tasks that Nikhil was
talking about earlier quickly.
Now, let's take a look
at how Pushblock works.
I'm going to switch
over to Cloud Shell.
Cloud Shell is
another GCP service
that allows you to use a command
line to manage all of your GCP
resources, as well
as a code editor.
And all of this is hosted
in a VM just for you
so you can access it from
the browser anytime you want.
So here, I am inside of this
Cloud Functions Repository.
And earlier today,
I was actually
testing out deploying
my Cloud Function
from a third-party service
to build a nice integration.
And because I was doing that,
I downloaded some GCP service
account credentials
to my machine.
Those are contained
in this key.json file.
Now later in the day,
I may go and make
an innocuous change,
such as fixing
this typo from this
repository to this repository.
And I'll track it with Git.
Make a quick comment
saying, fixing typo.
And push it to the server.
Now, you see I made
a mistake there.
I was going quick.
I just did a gitadd dot
that [? edited ?] everything
in the repository that wasn't
being tracked to be tracked.
And here we can see that
my push was rejected.
Pushblock has said
that the push has
been rejected because we detect
that it contains a private key.
Please check the
following commands
and confirm it's intentional.
I can go ahead and execute
this gitshow command,
and it will show the contents
of the private key, which
I'm not going to do on stage.
And if I detect
there was actually
something in there that
wasn't a private key,
and this was a
false detection, I
can go ahead and just
run gitpush and override,
to say I don't want a key check.
And with that, we've seen how
Pushblock and Cloud Source
Repositories can
help you [? from ?]
making those critical
mistakes that
can really put
your organization's
security at risk.
And with that, let's go ahead
and switch back to the slides.
And Nikhil can talk to
us about the next part
of our presentation,
which is deploying.
NIKHIL KAUL: So with that,
we finished the first part
of the presentation, which was
essentially developing an app.
When it comes to deploying
an app, many of us
are deploying to
different environments.
These could be VMs.
These could be containers.
These could be
serverless environments.
Or these could be
mobile platforms.
Irrespective of whether you're
using Google Compute Engine
VMs, Google Kubernetes
Engine for deploying
containers,
serverless frameworks,
such as App Engine or
functions, or mobile platforms,
like Firebase, Cloud Source
Repositories integration
with Cloud Build can come
in really handy here.
Cloud Build is Google's
continuous integration,
continuous delivery platform.
And Cloud Source Repositories
integrates with it.
In fact, as you would
see within the demo,
the good part about
the integration
is that there are no CS servers
to set up, manage, or maintain.
As you would see,
within a few clicks,
you will be able to
achieve automation
from source to production.
And the good thing is
you can deploy your app
to different environments.
In fact, if you are
someone who likes
to manage their build
configuration as code,
you can use cloudbuild.yaml
specifically
for specifying build steps.
You can specify
the steps you want
to perform as a part of build.
You can specify
the steps you want
to perform as a part of test.
And you can specify
the steps you
want to perform as a
part of deploy, as well.
The workflow looks
something like this.
As a developer,
I write the code,
and I check it in Cloud
Source Repositories.
From there on, Cloud
Build takes over.
And Cloud Build takes
over [? mainly ?]
because we have set
up a trigger to notify
Cloud Build that a code with
a change has been checked in.
Next, as Cloud Build
takes over, Cloud Build
can build both Docker
artifacts, as well as
non-container-specific
artifacts.
Example of these can be
Gradle, Maven, Go, Bazel, et
cetera, et cetera.
Once the artifacts
have been created,
Cloud Build can run
different types of tests,
whether these are unit
tests or integration tests.
If you're working with
containers specifically,
in the Artifact
Management space, which
is the fourth point
over there, Cloud Build
can help you scan
those artifacts for
[? vulnerabilities, ?] as well.
We'll talk more about
it in the later parts
of the presentation.
And finally, if
everything looks great,
you can deploy that app
to different environments
in the deployment phase.
However, when you're working
in a continuous integration
and continuous
delivery environment,
you need notifications as
a part of that process.
You might want notifications
during the start, as well as
the end.
And that's where the
notification piece
comes in handy.
RUSSELL WOLF: Both the Cloud
Source Repositories and Cloud
Build offer integrations
with Cloud Pub/Sub.
That means that when a
new commit is checked
into your repository, a
new bill is kicked off,
or a build completes, you
can generate a Pub/Sub event
to a Pub/Sub topic.
You can then have a
Cloud Function configured
to monitor that Pub/Sub
topic, watching out
for these new events coming in.
And when a new event comes in
and a Cloud Function triggers,
you can have it invoke
a third-party service
such as Slack,
Email, or any other
that you want to work with.
Before we go on to look
at a demo with this all,
I'm going ask Nikhil
to go ahead and walk us
through the workflow of what
we'll be doing in the demo.
NIKHIL KAUL: Sure.
So we've set up a
really simple demo
to demonstrate a
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery pipeline.
That's the first
phase of the demo.
And the second
phase of the demo is
essentially targeted at getting
a notification to Slack.
Let's break down
these two phases
and go into more
detail, one by one.
Both of these two
phases essentially
start at the same place, which
is developer writing a code
and checking it in into
Cloud Source Repositories.
In the first phase, what happens
is as developer writes a code
and checks it into Cloud Source
Repositories, a build gets
triggered, because
Cloud Build gets
a notification through the
build trigger which we have set.
Once the build gets
triggered, Cloud Build
essentially deploys the app to
the test version of App Engine
and runs end-to-end tests.
If the tests pass,
Cloud Build then
deploys the app to
the production version
of App Engine.
That completes the first phase
of the continuous integration
and continuous delivery process.
In the second stage,
what we are doing is
we are sending a
notification to Slack.
The steps look
something like this.
Starts again with developer
checking in the code.
Cloud Source Repositories
publishes that event
to Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Function then subscribes
to the Pub/Sub event.
And since it's subscribing
to the Pub/Sub event,
it posts the message which
it received in the event
to the Slack.
Let's see both of
these demos in action.
RUSSELL WOLF: Let's
switch over to the demos.
Here, we can see an application
already deployed to production.
It's a very simple app.
Basically, it's a guest book.
You can write a message in
this box here, such as Welcome
to Next 2019, sign
in the Guestbook,
and it's posted there along
with the user who wrote it.
You can switch over to
other Guestbooks, as well.
And they'll have a distinct
set of messages too.
And you can log-in and
log-out of this application.
Now, the title App
Engine Guestbook
maybe isn't the
most suitable one,
so let's go ahead and
change it to Next 2019
Guestbook, just something
easy for us to do here.
And we'll change
it first by going
to Cloud Source Repositories.
And I have no idea, actually,
where this code is declared.
But it's a simple code
change, so I can do it.
So I'm going to search
for App Engine Guestbook.
And it found the result
in one of these repos.
And I see it's here, so I
can just click Edit Code.
And this is now going to launch
me an instance of Cloud Shell.
It's going to make sure
that this repository is
mirrored into this VM.
And I'll have this complete
workspace in the cloud.
Here, I already have it
mirrored over, actually.
So it's just asking me
to change directory.
And I'm at that line of code.
So I'm going to change it
from App Engine to Next 2019.
We'll add this to Git.
We'll [? git ?] status
and make sure I'm not
checking in any security
keys, or anything like that.
[? Git commit-- ?]
I'm changing title.
And then finally, I'll
push it to the server.
Now, as this commit gets
pushed to the server,
just like Nikhil mentioned,
we're kicking off a build.
So let's switch over
to Cloud Build now.
And we can refresh and see that
a new build has been invoked.
Clicking into there, we can
see that as three distinct
build steps.
We'll dig into those into
detail in one minute.
Here, you can also see that
we have real time logs that
are being produced
from this build,
so we can see what's going on.
Let's go ahead and
take a look at this
build trigger that
we talked about.
So when code made it to
Cloud Source Repositories,
it kicked off this build
and told it what to do.
First, we notice that
there's a trigger type.
The trigger type allows
you to specify when you
want this trigger to activate.
You have the options
between a branch or a tag.
And here, I've chosen branch.
And I can choose a
regex that I want
to match for when I want
that build to be invoked.
In this case, I'm
doing a dot star
because I only have one branch.
And I just want to
trigger off that.
But I could also specify
an exact branch name
or regex for a set of branches
I want to kick off builds for.
I can also choose to filter
those build by changed files.
And so here, I could
use a regex to say,
I only want to trigger
builds if there are
changes in my source folder.
Or I don't want
to trigger builds
if it's just a change to a
config file or a markdown file.
Once you've decided when you
were going to invoke a build,
you then get to
decide what you want
to do when a build is invoked.
You do that inside of
Build Configuration
by choosing between
using a Docker file,
or a Cloud Build
configuration file.
In this case, we've used a
Cloud Build configuration file,
cloud.yaml.
Let's take a look
at this cloud.yaml.
We can jump back to Cloud
Source Repositories.
I could search for it,
but it's right here.
And so here, we can see
the first step that's
declared in the cloud.yaml.
This step says, we're going
to deploy the current code
to a test version on App
Engine without promoting it.
I'm just declaring
to use this existing
image stored in Container
Registry for G Cloud.
I'm saying to form the
[? app deploy ?] commands
and specifying the
app.yaml for App Engine
and an index.yaml for
the backing data store.
And then I'm specifying these
two parameters version tests.
So I'm naming that
version, and I'm
saying not to promote
it to production.
After that, if and only
if that step completes,
I proceed to the
next step, which
runs end-to-end tests against
the test version on App Engine.
So here, I'm just
using another image
that's already stored on
Container Registry, which
is an Ubuntu image.
I'm opening into Bash,
installing some prerequisites,
and then executing this
runtests.bash script.
Here, we can see I'm just
declaring the URL for my test
environment on App Engine.
And I'm executing
the end-to-end tests.
If those tests all
succeed, I proceed
to the next step, which
deploys the current code
to a new version on App Engine.
That's promoted to
serve production.
Again, I just use
that G Cloud image
and call that same app deploy.
But this time, I'm not
naming it to a test version,
and I am letting it
promote to production.
That's really all there is for
setting up this automated test
environment, running
my end-to-end tests,
as well as promoting to
production if those succeed.
I recognize many of you
might not use App Engine.
There are many other
deployment run times.
If you were to
deploy to Kubernetes,
there's Cloud Build
steps for that.
If you wanted to deploy
to Cloud Functions,
it's as simple as specifying
your function name.
And finally, there's
even steps if you're
trying to go to mobile, and
you want to deploy to Firebase.
Now that we've seen how
the cloudbuild.yaml does
that final part of showing
what we should build,
let's return to the build
and see what's happened.
Here, we can go back
to Build History.
And it looks like
the build succeeded.
We can see that that
first step of deploying
to App Engine in
this test environment
and not promoting
it took 17 seconds.
Spinning up that Ubuntu
image, installing
a bunch of these
prerequisites, and then running
our end-to-end integration
tests took another 54 seconds.
But they did pass,
so that's good.
And finally, deploying to
production and promoting
took another 30 seconds.
Let's go ahead and check out
our application on production.
We can refresh this page,
and we see that it's now
updated to Next 2019 Guestbook.
Now that we've seen how that
CI/CD automated workflow
works, let's take a look at
that other part of the demo
that Nikhil talked
about, which is
posting the messages
to Slack automatically
to inform your team.
So here, I have a Cloud
Function already created,
called CSR to Slack.
It's watching this Pub/Sub
topic I've called CSR.
And I've told Cloud
Source Repositories
to post Pub/Sub events
to that CSR topic
whenever something happens,
like a new commit coming in.
I'm then pulling source
code for this Cloud Function
from a different Cloud
Source Repository
and executing this
message Slack function.
Here, we can again go to
Cloud Source Repositories
and take a look at
what that looks like.
Finds it right away for me.
And we can see that
in this function,
I'm going to be messaging
the Next 2019 channel saying
that user's email just pushed a
new commit to this repository.
So let's go over
to Slack, and we
can see that it indeed did post
that message to that channel.
Whether you're
trying to interact
with Slack or any other
third-party service,
integrations with Cloud
Pub/Sub and Cloud Functions
make it really easy.
Now that we've
looked at this demo,
I'm going to let Nikhil
tell us a little bit more
about some of the
deploy technologies
that we have that are
specific to containers.
So let's go ahead and switch
back to the slides now.
NIKHIL KAUL: So far,
what Russell's showed
in the presentation was really
catered towards App Engine.
But many of you in
the audience might
be using containers
on a day-to-day basis
to deploy applications.
If you're working
with containers,
as a part of Cloud Build,
we have something called
as vulnerability scanning.
Vulnerability
scanning allows you
to identify security
vulnerabilities
early on in the software
development process.
Package vulnerabilities
for Ubuntu, Debian
are identified right as soon
as the containers are built.
It also provides you
detailed insight,
by providing details
such as the severity
level of the vulnerability,
what is the CVSS score,
and whether a fix is available.
In fact, if you want to take
this process to the next level
and further automate
your tool chain,
you can use
vulnerability scanning
with binary authorization, which
will be going [INAUDIBLE] soon.
Binary authorization essentially
lets you define policies based
upon your organization needs.
For instance, as
an organization,
you can decide
and define that we
get to deploy only those
containers which are actually
tested.
What this means is if some
developer actually ends up
deploying a container
which was not
tested as a part of
CI/CD tool chain,
that container will
not get deployed.
The [? imageable ?]
here is essentially
doing something else, however.
What we're doing over
here is developer
checks a code into
Cloud Source Repository.
Cloud Build creates a build.
The container gets scanned
by vulnerability scanning.
And then essentially,
binary authorization checks
for a signature on the image
from vulnerability scanning.
If a signature is
found, the container
is deployed to Google
Kubernetes Engine.
And if a signature is
not found, audit log
is provided on why the specific
steps were not performed.
With that, we have
essentially completed
2/3 of the presentation.
We specifically looked
at developing an app.
We specifically also
looked at deploying an app
by showcasing the Cloud Build
integration with Cloud Source
Repositories.
However, as a developer,
many times we also face
challenges where we
have to debug an app,
especially in production.
And we're not able
to replicate those
issues on a local environment.
And that's where Cloud
Source Repositories'
integration with Stackdriver
really comes in handy.
There are essentially
two ways which
we allow you to debug
your app in production.
The first and the
foremost way is
Stackdriver's was
debug snapshots.
This comes in really
handy when you're actually
debugging an app in production.
Let's take the following
example as an instance.
You're trying to debug
an app in production,
but that issue is being faced
only by one specific user.
And as a result of
which, identifying
that issue on your
local environment
becomes really
difficult. And this
is where Stackdriver's debug
snapshot provides you details.
It captures the
entire call stacks.
It inspects the local variables.
In fact, to do this
you do not even
have to slow down
or stop your app.
And the best part is once you
select the lines on which you
have to set up these
debug snapshots,
all your running
instances of the app
can start
automatically capturing
these debug snapshots.
The other way of debugging
with Stackdriver is log points.
RUSSELL WOLF: As Nikhil said,
Stackdriver Debugger also lets
you set debug log points.
Debug log points allow you
to set a custom log message
on a particular line of code.
That custom log message
can then reference
the current application
state, as well as only log
under certain conditions.
For example, you may want to
log the value of a variable
only if the value
of that variable
is outside of an expected range.
I like to think of it kind
of like printf debugging,
except you don't need a
single printf in your code.
And since you're using
Stackdriver Debugger
in production.
It's important
that you don't even
need to restart or
stop your application.
Finally, Stackdriver
Debugger also
integrates with
Stackdriver logging,
which means that you can store,
search, analyze, and alert,
on these debug events.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at debug snapshots and debug
log points in a demo again.
Can we switch over
to the demo, please?
Here, we can see the Stackdriver
Debugger user interface.
At the top, we have
a service selector.
This allows us to choose
between the various services
and versions of those services
that we have deployed.
I'm going to go ahead and
switch over to the one
that we've now
promoted to 100% and is
backed by the Cloud
Source Repository
at the commit we just made.
Stackdriver Debugger
automatically
pulls in that source
code and allows
me to navigate through
the entire file tree.
We're looking at
guestbook.py now,
which is where the bulk of
the logic for this application
exists.
Now when a user goes
in and posts a message
to the application, that happens
within this function down here,
called post.
Now, I'm sure you've all
been in situations where
you've had a user running
up against your production
service.
They're running into a problem.
You try reproing it locally.
It doesn't repro.
You try reproing it on your
production service as well,
and you just can't repro it.
Stackdriver Debugger can
come in to help a lot
with those types of situations.
Here, I can go ahead and
go into my snapshot panel
and set a condition
saying, user email
equals
cloudsourcerepositories2019--
which is the name of the email
I'm currently logged in with--
@gmail.com.
And let's go ahead
and set this snapshot
on the greeting.put,
which is where we're
going to insert the greeting
someone signs in a guestbook
into our data store.
And now we have a
snapshot waiting there.
You know, it may be in
the next five minutes.
It could be in the next day.
But when a user comes in
with that email address,
it's going to capture the
exact application state
that that user was looking at.
So we can find out what
was happening for them.
We can also set
debug log points.
And so in the meantime, while
we're waiting for that user,
I kind of want to see what's
happening for other users.
So I can go in and
click on that same line.
And for now, I'm just
going to say, if true.
So I'm always going to have
this debug log happen every time
someone posts a message.
And I'm just going to say,
email and log the user email.
I can then choose to
add that debug log
point as informational, as
a warning, or as an error.
And as I said
earlier, all of that
integrates back with
all of your other
logs in the Stackdriver logging.
So I'm going to add that log.
And now, we just wait
for something to happen.
So let's go over
to the application
and make something happen.
So I'm going to sign the
guestbook again saying,
thank you all for
coming to our talk.
And the guestbook is signed.
And we can return
to Cloud Debugger.
Here, we can return
to the snapshot.
And we can see that the
snapshot was captured.
This user posted in
the default guestbook,
and that looks right.
That's the one I
currently have selected.
And it matched the user
email that I was specifically
looking for.
I can then dig into the
other local variables,
such as inside greeting.
I can see the value of the
message that was written,
such as thank you all
for coming to the talk,
as well as seeing the entire
call stack of the application
at that point to see if maybe
something was executed that I
didn't expect to be executed.
I can also go in and
look at our logs.
And by refreshing the logs, I
can see that, indeed, this log
point was hit.
And we now have a log
in our logging system
saying this user visited.
And we get that, if any
other user visited as well.
So I hope you all enjoyed
seeing Stackdriver Debugger.
It's actually one of my
favorite tools we have on GCP.
And I highly suggest
you give it a try.
I'm going to hand
it back to Nikhil
now to wrap things up and
explain the main takeaways
from our talk.
NIKHIL KAUL: Thanks, Russell.
RUSSELL WOLF: Will you please
switch back to the slides?
NIKHIL KAUL: So today, we
saw three specific things.
We spoke about developing in
applications using Cloud Source
Repositories.
During that stage,
we specifically
saw mirroring source code
from GitHub and Bitbucket
to Cloud Source Repositories.
We spoke about how GitLab
integration is coming soon.
As a part of that process, we
also spoke about code search
and how code search
lets you search
across all the repositories
you have access to.
We showcased Pushblock
functionality,
which ensures that security keys
are not stored within source
control management systems.
That completed the first part.
During the second
piece, we specifically
spoke about Cloud Source
Repositories' integration
with Cloud Build, which lets
you automate your build, test,
and deployment process
of your pipeline.
In case you're working
with containers,
we spoke about how you can
leverage container registry
vulnerability scanning along
with binary authorization
to set up specific policies.
And finally, in the third
part of the presentation,
we spoke about how you
can use Stackdriver
to debug applications
in production.
With that, thank you
so much for coming.
We are still over here
for any questions.
And we would really
appreciate it
if you could provide your
feedback in the Next app.
We hope to see you again.
Thanks, a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]